inial pru plus de première classe une
classe unique pour le métro ce projet de
la ratp fait couler beaucoup d'encre
depuis quelques jours on peut même
parler de polémique à ce propos car
comme toujours quand il s'agit de
modifier quelque chose d'ancré dans les
faits depuis plusieurs décennies
il y a les partisans et il ya les
opposants de choses à noter dans cette
affaire ce projet est un vieux projet il
date de 76 il n'est donc pas lié à
l'arrivée du communiste claude qu'à la
tête de la régie et puis l'autre chose
c'est que selon les propres chiffres de
la ratp
la suppression de la première classe ne
concerneraient directement que 4,5 pour
cent des usagers dominique bâillon nous
explique pourquoi la ratp envisagent de
supprimer cette fameuse première classe
voici le dernier obstacle la suppression
des premières classes ceram date de 1935
et elles n'offrent aux voyageurs de
seconde place que d'un confortables
banquettes en bois
mais l'an prochain ces vestiges du
métropolitain seront définitivement
réformer et la régie offrira à tous ses
clients un confort suffisant pour que
tout le monde soit logé à la même
enseigne
autrement dit quoi ya jean classe unique
autre facteur qui pourrait justifier la
suppression des premières le rer a
permis de les charger les lignes de
métro les plus fréquentes
d'autre part les utilisateurs des
premières se font de plus en plus rares
il représentait 6,5 pour cent des
voyageurs en 75 ils ne représentent
aujourd'hui que 4 5%
mais c'est bien sûr chez ce petit nombre
d'habitués des premières qu'une
éventuelle suppression de la première
place suscite le plus de style it et
pensez qu'il faut maintenir et premier
plan' je pense mais pourquoi chercher
une personne au fait c'est pas plus de
place pour les gens de secours ont
essayé les gens en seconde où je ne
partirai pas le cas même le première
classe
l'essentiel ce sont des personnes âgées
qui ont besoin de s'asseoir
d'une part d'autre part du point de vue
économique
la ratp va perdre pas mal de rentrer aux
griffes de prendre deux premières ne
en jeu
ça doit se faire maintenant il mesure
égalitaire qui nécessaire
je pense que c'est mieux
j'espère que ça se produira mais là
la sncm
mais l'égalité sociale aurait son revers
la ratp estime que la suppression des
premières lui occasionnerait une perte
de recettes d'au moins 50 millions
il faudrait bien un compenser d'une
façon ou d'une autre suppression ou
maintient la régie pourrait prendre sa
décision avant la fin de l'année
un vêtement masse